>> Tucker: WELL, GOOD EVENING,
WELCOME TO TUCKER KARLTON SONT.
THERE WAS AN UNEXPECTED AND KIND
OF AMAZING MOMENT AT THE WHITE
HOUSE TODAY.
KANYE WEST, THE RAPPER, SHOWED
UP IN THE OVAL OFFICE.
AND PROCEEDED TO GIVE WHAT
AMOUNTED TO EFFECTIVELY A
CAMPAIGN SPEECH SITTING DIRECTLY
ACROSS FROM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES AND POUNDING ON
THE PRESIDENTIAL DESK.
YOU'VE LIKELY SEEN PICTURES OF
WHAT HAPPENED EVERYWHERE.
THE SCENE MAY HAVE CONFUSED YOU.
YOU MIGHT HAVE CORN CLUEDTED IT
WAS A PUBLICITY STUNT STAGED BY
FAMOUS PEOPLE TO BECOME MORE
FAMOUS.
YOU MAY HAVE FOUND YOURSELF
MUPTERRING ABOUT THE CELEBRITIES
CENTERED FOCUS OF THE PUBLIC
DISCOURSE.
FELT SAD KNOWING THAT THE
DIGNIFIED COUNTRY YOU GREW UP IN
IS GONE FOR GOOD.
YOU CAN BE FOR GIVEN FOR
REACHING THOSE CONCLUSIONS.
THEY'RE NOT THE WHOLE STORY OF
WHAT HAPPENED.
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, KANYE WEST
HAD GENUINELY INTERESTING THINGS
THIS AFTERNOON TO SAY.
THINGS WE OUGHT TO BE TALKING
ABOUT IN PUBLIC BUT ARE NOT.
PROBABLY DESTROY HIS CAREER FOR
SAYING THEM, CERTAINLY WILL BE
DESPISED BY MANY OF HIS FORMER
FRIENDS.
BEFORE ANY OF THAT HAPPENS,
LET'S CONSIDER WHAT HE ACTUALLY
SAID.
WE'LL GO WITH THE MOST OFFENSIVE
THINGS FIRST.
HERE THEY ARE.
>> YEAH, PEOPLE EFFECT THAT IF
YOU'RE BLACK YOU HAVE TO BE
DEMOCRAT.
I HAVE, I HAVE CONVERSATION THAT
IS BASICALLY, SAID, THAT WELFARE
IS THE REASON WHY A LOT OF BLACK
PEOPLE END UP BEING DEMOCRATS.
THEY SAY, FIRST OF ALL, IT IS A
LIMIT TO A AMOUNT OF JOBS.
THE FATHERS LOSE THE JOBS AND
THEY SAY WE'LL GET YOU MORE
MONEY FOR HAVING MORE KIDS IN
YOUR HOME.
I THINK IT'S THE BRAVERY THAT
HELPS YOU BEAT THE GAME CALLED
LIFE.
THEY TRY TO SCARE ME TO NOT WEAR
THIS HAT.
MY OWN FRIENDS.
THIS HAT GIVES ME, IT GIVES ME
POWER IN A WAY.
YOU KNOW, MY DAD, AND MY MOM,
SEPARATED.
SO I CAN'T HAVE A LOT OF MALE
ENERGY IN MY HOME.
YOU KNOW, I LOVE HILLARY, I LOVE
EVERYONE, RIGHT?
BUT THE CAMPAIGN, WITH HER,
DIDN'T MAKE ME FEEL AS A GUY
DIDN'T GET TO SEE MY DAD ALL THE
TIME, LIKE A GUY THAT COULD FLAY
CATCH WITH HIS SON.
>> Tucker: ME DIDN'T MAKE ME
FEEL LIKE A GUY WHO COULD PLAY
CATCH WITH HIS SON.
WEST DIDN'T EXPLAIN WHAT HE
MEANT BY THAT, AND YET AT THE
VERY TAME TIME COULDN'T HAVE PUT
IT MORE PRECISELY OR POIGNANTLY.
HE GREW UP IN A PARTY WHOSE
POLICIES HAVE SAYS ME MATICALLY
'DROID -- SYSTEMATICALLY
DESTROYED THE AMERICAN FAMILY.
DIDN'T HAVE A LOT OF MALE IN MY
HOME.
MILLIONS OF KIDS KNOW WHAT HE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY WON'T
ACKNOWLEDGE THE KIDS OR THEIR
LOSS.
TO PARTY LEADERS FATHERS IN THE
HOME ARE AT BEST IRRELEVANT, AT
WORSE THE IMPEDIMENT TO
POLITICAL POWER.
MARRIED WOMEN TEND TO VOTE
REPUBLICAN AND THEY KNOW THAT.
WHEN PROMINENT DEMOCRATS ATTACK
THE PAY TREE AR CAN I, THEY'RE
ATTACKING FATHERS.
WHEN THEY WAGE WAR ON TOXIC
MASCULINITY, THEY'RE TRYING TO
SUPPRESS MASCULINITY ITSELF.
FEW ARE BRAVE ENOUGH TO SAY IT
OUTLOUD, WEST DID AND THEN KEPT
GOING.
WATCH THIS.
>> SO, ONE OF THE MOVES THAT I
LOVE THAT LIBERALS TRY TO DO,
THE LIBERAL WOULD TRY TO CONTROL
A BLACK PERSON THROUGH THE
CONCEPT OF RACISM, THEY KNOW
WE'RE VERY PROUD, EMOTIONAL
PEOPLE.
WHEN I SAID I LIKE TRUMP, TO
SOME ONE THAT'S LIBERAL, THEY'LL
SAY BUT HE'S RACE INTEREST.
YOU THINK RACISM COULD CONTROL
ME?
OH, THAT DON'T STOP ME, THAT'S
AN INVISIBLE WALL.
>> Tucker: YOU THINK RACISM CAN
CONTROL ME, IT'S AN INVISIBLE
WALL.
THE REPORTERS LOOKING ON SEEMED
STUNNED, EVEN BETRAYED.
AND THEN JUST TO RUB IT IN, WEST
WENT ON TO DEFEND THE BILL OF
RIGHTS, WATCH.
>> WHAT ABOUT GUN VIOLENCE WITH
THE DEBATE ABOUT THE SECOND
AMENDMENT?
>> THE PROBLEM IS ILLEGAL GUNS,
NOT LEGAL GUNS.
WE HAVE THE RIGHT TO BEAR ARMS.
>> Tucker: WHAT DO WE MAKE OF
ALL OF THIS?
FROM WATCHING CAN YOU TELL THAT
KANYE WEST IS AN ECCENTRIC GUY,
HE MEANDERS, HE TALKS LIKE SOME
ONE WHO HAS NEVER HAD TO FILTER
HIS THOUGHTS.
PROBABLY NEVER DID DO.
MUCH LIKE SOME ONE ELSE WHO
COMES TO MIND ME MAY BE
PRECISELY CRAZY ENOUGH TO THINK
FOR HIMSELF A VALUABLE QUALITY
RIGHT NOW.
NO CONSULTANT ADVISED HIM TO SAY
ANY OF THAT, NOBODY CONTROLS
HIM.
SOMETIMES HE DOESN'T CONTROL
HIMSELF.
BUT LISTEN CAREFULLY TO WHAT HE
SAID.
SPRINKLED THROUGHOUT THE
RAMBLINGS ARE FLASHES OF TRUTH.
REAL INSIGHTS INTO THE WAY THE
WORLD ACTUALLY RACE THEY ARE
THAN THE WAY THEY TELL US IT IS.
NOBODY ELSE IS ALLOWED TO TALK
THIS WAY.
GO AHEAD AND TRY IT AT WORK,
YOU'LL GET FIRED.
WEST DOESN'T CARE.
THAT MAKES HIM DANGEROUS TO A
SYSTEM THAT'S BASED ALMOST
ENTIRELY ON PIETY AND LYING.
IF YOU'RE BENEFITTING FROM THE
SYSTEM LIKE THAT KANYE WEST MUST
BE CRUSHED.
THE MATH OF IT, THE DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL CANDIDATES, NEEDS
TO GET ALMOST THE ENTIRE BLACK
VOTE TO WIN A NATIONAL ELECTION.
THAT'S NOT EASY TO DO.
IN ORDER TO DO IT, DEMOCRATS PIT
AMERICANS AGAINST EACH OTHER
BASED ON ETHNICITY.
YOU CAN'T SUPPORT THEM, THEY'RE
THE WRONG COLOR.
YOU HEAR THAT ALL THE TIME, THE
ESSENTIAL DEMOCRATIC ARGUMENT.
IT'S DESTRUCTIVE BUT FOR
DEMOCRATS I MAY NOT BE WORKING.
TRUMP'S APPROVAL RATING WITH
HISPANIC VOTERS IS 41%, LARGER
THAN COLLEGE EDUCATED WHITE
VOTERS.
IF ANYTHING LIKE THAT HAPPENED
AMONG AFRICAN-AMERICAN VOTERS
THE GAME WOULD BE OVER.
SO THAT CAN'T HAPPEN.
KANYE WEST MUST BE DESTROYED.
SO THE THOUGHT POLICE SWOOPED IN
ALMOST IMMEDIATELY TO ARREST
THIS DISOBEDIENT ARTIST AND
DECLARE HIM INCOMPETENT.
>> WOW.
OKAY, I'M DOING THIS FOR
EVERYBODY WHO'S WATCHING, WHO
TURNED THEIR VOLUME DOWN.
YOU CAN PUT IT BACK UP AGAIN.
>> IF YOU THINK YOU'RE GOING TO
GET A THOUGHTFUL PLAY-BY-PLAY
AND POLITICAL ANALYSIS YOU ARE
NOT.
THAT WAS AN ASSAULT ON OUR WHITE
HOUSE.
>> A COMBINATION OF STREAM OF
CONSCIOUSNESS, I FELT LIKE I WAS
SITTING IN ON A PSYCHIATRIC
VISIT, AND A COMMERCIAL FOR
DONALD TRUMP.
>> WHAT I SAW WAS A MINSTREL
SHOW.
HIM EMBARRASSING HIMSELF AND
EMBARRASSING AMERICANS BUT
MOSTLY AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
>> Tucker: SHUT UP, KANYE,
YOU'RE CRAZY.
KEEP IN MIND THIS COMING FROM
THE SAME PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE
HILLARY CLINTON IS ENTIRELY
WELL.
INDEED A SERIOUS PERSON.
THEY HOPE THIS WORKS, THIS CRAZY
STUFF, AND THAT YOU BELIEVE THEM
N CASE YOU DON'T, THEY WANTED TO
REMIND YOU THAT KANYE WEST IS A
RACE TRADER AS DON MEM ON SAID,
WHO HAS A LOW I.Q.
HERE WAS CNN TUESDAY NIGHT.
>> KANYE WEST IS WHAT HAPPENS
WHEN NEGROS DON'T READ.
AND WE HAVE THIS, NOW, AND NOW
DONALD TRUMP IS GOING TO USE IT
AND PERVERT IT.
HE'S GOING TO HAVE SOMEBODY TO
STAND WITH HIM AND TAKE
PICTURES.
>> KANYE, HE PUT ON A MAGA HAT,
ATTENTION WHORE LIKE THE
PRESIDENT, HE'S THE MODEL
SPOKESPERSON, HE'S THE TOKEN
NEGRO OF THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION?
>> Tucker: YOU GOT THAT?
HE CAN'T READ BECAUSE HE'S THE
"N" WORD.
THAT'S WHAT THE LIBERALS ON A
LIBERAL CABLE CHANNEL ARE NOW
TELLING YOU.